(light piano music)
- People need to understand
that all of North America
is indigenous land.
It is Native land.
(light piano music)
People tend to forget that there was
a vibrant Native culture
living in all parts of North America.
And food is really the piece
that's going to help us move forward
into a brighter future.
(light piano music)
My name is Sean Sherman
and I am a chef.
I own the company The Sioux Chef.
So this is gonna be two
pieces per plate for these.
Our mission is revitalizing
Native American foods
and re-identifying North American cuisine.
We've tried really hard
to maintain authenticity
by removing all of the
colonial ingredients
like dairy, wheat flour, processed sugar
beef, pork, chicken
and we're just using a lot of wild game
a lot of the native agricultural
heirloom varietals, a lot
of the wild foods around us
and really making those plates
that taste like a region.
Most of these ingredients
are very familiar to people
but the usage of a lot of the wild plants
really talk about a place in a community.
We prioritize purchasing from
the indigenous vendors first
because we really want to
open up a lot of opportunity
for indigenous people growing out farms
or collecting things from the wild
or raising animals.
So for the big dinner
we're actually cooking this bison down
with a bunch of fresh
cedar and some bergamot.
We will purchase from anybody
raising these indigenous pieces
because it is such an important part
of the landscape and the history.
I know you want it.
As we travel around the country
we like to make dinners and foods
that really represent those areas.
What's great about being
able to do these dinners
especially in non-indigenous communities
is just to bring awareness.
This kind of food that we're eating today
like, you're gonna feel really
good when you leave here.
You're not gonna feel
heavy and weighted down.
You're gonna feel energized and just happy
because you're knowing where
this food is coming from.
We feel like anybody across North America
will benefit from the understanding
of the indigenous food systems around you.
And it's all gonna help us move forward.
(uplifting music)